selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum Information and Computation, nama saya John Watrous dan saya adalah direktur teknis
untuk pendidikan di IBM Quantum. Ini adalah pelajaran ke-11 dari seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran ketiga dalam
unit ketiga yang membahas tentang formulasi umum informasi Quantum. Pelajaran ini tentang pengukuran yang merupakan
antarmuka antara informasi Quantum dan klasik. Ketika pengukuran dilakukan pada sebuah sistem saat sistem berada dalam
keadaan Quantum, informasi klasik diekstraksi yang mengungkapkan sesuatu tentang keadaan Quantum tersebut dan umumnya mengubah atau
menghancurkan keadaan itu dalam prosesnya. Dalam formulasi Quantum information yang disederhanakan yang dibahas
di unit pertama seri ini, kita biasanya membatasi perhatian pada pengukuran projektif termasuk
tipe pengukuran yang paling sederhana yaitu pengukuran basis standar. Namun memang mungkin untuk menggeneralisasi konsep pengukuran
dan itu ternyata menjadi hal yang cukup berguna untuk dilakukan. Dalam pelajaran ini kita akan membicarakan tentang pengukuran secara penuh
termasuk bagaimana pengukuran dideskripsikan dalam istilah matematika dan bagaimana mereka masuk ke dalam formulasi umum Quantum
information. Menjelang akhir pelajaran kita juga akan melihat beberapa konsep mendasar yang terkait dengan pengukuran yaitu diskriminasi Quantum State
dan tomografi Quantum State. Jadi mari kita mulai. Berikut gambaran umum
pelajaran. Seperti yang sering kita lakukan, kita akan mulai dengan hal-hal dasar termasuk beberapa cara yang berbeda tapi ekuivalen yang bisa kita
gunakan untuk mendeskripsikan pengukuran dalam istilah matematika. Khususnya, kita bisa mendeskripsikan pengukuran dengan koleksi matriks
dan kita juga bisa mendeskripsikannya sebagai channel yang saya singgung di pelajaran sebelumnya. Kita juga akan mendiskusikan pengukuran parsial,
atau dengan kata lain pengukuran yang dilakukan hanya pada satu bagian dari sistem majemuk yang lebih besar.
Kemudian kita akan beralih ke teorema Naimark yang merupakan fakta mendasar tentang pengukuran yang pada dasarnya
mengatakan bahwa pengukuran umum selalu bisa diimplementasikan dengan cara sederhana yang mengingatkan pada representasi Stinespring
dari channel. Singkatnya, pengukuran umum selalu bisa diimplementasikan dengan pertama memperkenalkan
sistem workspace yang sudah diinisialisasi, kemudian melakukan operasi unitary, dan akhirnya melakukan pengukuran basis standar
pada sistem workspace. Ini ternyata cukup mudah untuk dibuktikan dan kita akan lihat bagaimana caranya, dan
kita juga akan lihat bagaimana ini terhubung dengan yang disebut pengukuran non-destruktif yang akan saya deskripsikan. Terakhir, di bagian terakhir
pelajaran ini, kita akan mendiskusikan diskriminasi Quantum State dan tomografi Quantum State. Kita akan mulai dengan deskripsi matematika
dari pengukuran. Pengukuran memberikan kita antarmuka antara Quantum dan
informasi klasik. Ketika pengukuran dilakukan pada sebuah sistem saat berada dalam keadaan Quantum tertentu, informasi klasik
tentang keadaan Quantum itu diekstraksi. Selain itu, keadaan Quantum umumnya berubah atau mungkin
hancur sepenuhnya. Awalnya kita akan fokus pada yang disebut pengukuran destruktif di mana
keadaan Quantum masuk dan hanya informasi klasik yang keluar, jadi tidak ada spesifikasi
tentang keadaan Quantum sistem yang diukur setelah pengukuran. Secara intuitif, kita bisa membayangkan bahwa pengukuran destruktif
menghancurkan sistem apapun yang diukur sehingga keadaannya setelah pengukuran berlangsung tidak
dispesifikasikan. Ini tidak secara harfiah berarti bahwa perangkat fisik pasti hancur, ini hanyalah deskripsi matematika
dan ini sangat berguna karena membantu menjaga segalanya tetap sederhana dan fokus pada aspek
matematika penting dari pengukuran. Ada khususnya dua cara ekuivalen untuk mendeskripsikan pengukuran destruktif
yang saya sebutkan selama gambaran umum pelajaran. Satu cara untuk mendeskripsikan pengukuran destruktif
adalah dengan koleksi matriks di mana khususnya kita punya satu matriks untuk setiap kemungkinan hasil pengukuran.
Cara kedua untuk mendeskripsikan pengukuran destruktif adalah dengan channel di mana
input adalah keadaan dari sistem apapun yang sedang diukur dan outputnya selalu berupa matriks densitas diagonal yang bisa kita
interpretasikan sebagai deskripsi distribusi probabilitas atas kemungkinan hasil pengukuran klasik.
Kedua deskripsi tersebut ekuivalen dan itu cukup berguna karena memungkinkan kita memilih deskripsi mana yang lebih nyaman dalam situasi tertentu.
Kita juga akan membicarakan tentang pengukuran non-destruktif di mana selain hasil pengukuran klasik,
keadaan Quantum dari sistem yang diukur setelah pengukuran juga
dispesifikasikan. Pengukuran non-destruktif itu penting dan sering muncul tapi ada rasa di mana
mereka entah bagaimana tidak se-fundamental pengukuran destruktif dalam istilah matematika. Khususnya, seperti yang ternyata,
pengukuran non-destruktif selalu bisa dideskripsikan sebagai komposisi dari channel dan pengukuran destruktif, dan
kita akan lihat cara kerjanya sedikit kemudian dalam pelajaran. Sekarang mari lihat bagaimana pengukuran, yaitu pengukuran destruktif,
bisa dideskripsikan sebagai koleksi matriks. Sepanjang diskusi ini kita akan mengasumsikan bahwa X adalah sistem yang
sedang diukur dan hanya untuk kesederhanaan kita akan membuat beberapa asumsi. Pertama, kita akan mengasumsikan bahwa
himpunan keadaan klasik dari X terdiri dari bilangan bulat dari 0 sampai N minus satu untuk bilangan bulat positif N tertentu, dan kemungkinan
hasil dari pengukuran adalah bilangan bulat dari 0 sampai M minus satu, sekali lagi untuk bilangan bulat positif M tertentu. Tidak ada
kebutuhan untuk ada hubungan antara angka N dan M, keduanya adalah bilangan bulat positif yang sembarang, dan tentu saja kita bisa mengganti
himpunan-himpunan ini dengan himpunan keadaan klasik yang sembarang jika kita mau melakukan itu. Pertama mari ingat bagaimana pengukuran projektif
bekerja yang pertama kita bicarakan kembali di pelajaran ketiga dari seri ini. Dengan asumsi bahwa
hasil pengukuran adalah bilangan bulat dari 0 sampai N minus satu, kita mendeskripsikan pengukuran projektif dengan koleksi
dari proyeksi Pi 0 sampai Pi M minus satu yang berjumlah ke matriks identitas, dan matriks-matriks ini semua memiliki baris dan
kolom yang bersesuaian dengan keadaan klasik dari X, atau dengan kata lain ini semua adalah matriks N kali N.
Jika X berada dalam keadaan Quantum yang dideskripsikan oleh vektor keadaan Quantum S, maka setiap kemungkinan hasil pengukuran
A muncul dengan probabilitas sama dengan norma Euclidean kuadrat dari Pi A dikalikan
ke vektor S. Norma Euclidean kuadrat dari vektor manapun sama dengan hasil kali dalam dari vektor tersebut
dengan dirinya sendiri, sehingga kita mendapat ekspresi yang ditunjukkan di layar, dan kita bisa menyederhanakan itu sedikit
dengan menggunakan fakta bahwa Pi A adalah proyeksi sehingga mengalikannya dengan dirinya sendiri tidak
melakukan apa-apa. Dan akhirnya kita bisa menulis ulang ekspresi yang kita peroleh dengan cara yang sedikit berbeda menggunakan sifat siklik
WEBVTT
dari jejak sekali lagi seperti yang ditunjukkan di layar. Dan jika tidak jelas mengapa kita ingin menulis ekspresi seperti ini,
jawaban singkatnya adalah bahwa kita ingin memahami bagaimana pengukuran projektif bekerja untuk matriks
densitas. Dan khususnya berdasarkan linearitas, kita punya bahwa jika keadaan X dideskripsikan oleh matriks densitas rho bukan
vektor keadaan Quantum S, maka probabilitas untuk hasil A muncul diberikan oleh jejak dari proyeksi
Pi A dikali matriks densitas rho. Itu harus begitu karena seperti yang telah kita lihat,
kita selalu bisa memikirkan matriks densitas sebagai rata-rata tertimbang dari keadaan murni, dan jika kita merata-ratakan
probabilitas yang bersesuaian, kita mendapat ekspresi ini karena jejak adalah fungsi linear. Jadi itulah ekspresi yang kita
cari, dan kita bisa sedikit merapikannya untuk fokus pada matriks
densitas. Poin utama dari melakukan ini omong-omong adalah untuk menetapkan titik referensi dengan apa yang sudah kita pelajari
dan untuk melihat bahwa deskripsi pengukuran projektif ini sebenarnya adalah kasus khusus dari deskripsi yang lebih umum tentang pengukuran yang akan
kita lihat sebentar lagi. Jadi yang akan saya lakukan sekarang adalah mengganti deskripsi tentang bagaimana pengukuran projektif bekerja untuk matriks densitas
dengan deskripsi untuk pengukuran umum sehingga kita bisa memahami hubungannya, dan begini
dia. Pengukuran umum, tidak harus pengukuran projektif, dideskripsikan oleh koleksi matriks positif semi-definitif
P 0 sampai PM minus satu yang berjumlah ke identitas. Dan jika pengukuran ini dilakukan pada X saat
berada dalam keadaan yang dideskripsikan oleh matriks densitas rho, maka setiap hasil A muncul dengan probabilitas sama dengan jejak dari PA dikali
rho. Singkatnya, satu-satunya hal yang berubah adalah bahwa kita sudah melonggarkan kondisi pada matriks-matriks ini. Khususnya, matriks-matriks
tersebut tidak perlu menjadi matriks proyeksi, mereka hanya perlu bersifat positif semi-definitif. Dan yang bersesuaian, saya mengganti huruf Pi dengan huruf P
karena Pi adalah nama konvensional untuk proyeksi, sedangkan saya suka menggunakan huruf P untuk matriks positif semi-definitif.
Ini adalah generalisasi dari deskripsi yang kita miliki untuk pengukuran projektif omong-omong, karena matriks proyeksi selalu positif
semi-definitif. Dan sebenarnya mereka secara alternatif bisa didefinisikan sebagai matriks positif semi-definitif yang nilai eigennya
hanya bisa nol atau satu. Kita bisa amati bahwa definisi ini
masuk akal dalam arti bahwa kita selalu mendapatkan vektor probabilitas untuk probabilitas hasil dengan cara
berikut. Pertama, angka-angka yang saya sebut sebagai probabilitas hasil selalu bilangan real non-negatif. Itu
karena PA dan rho keduanya positif semi-definitif dan jejak dari perkalian dua matriks positif semi-definitif
selalu bilangan real non-negatif. Dan saya akan biarkan itu untukmu pikirkan mengapa demikian.
Dan kedua, angka-angka itu harus berjumlah satu karena jejak bersifat linear, matriks
P 0 sampai PN minus 1 disyaratkan berjumlah ke identitas, dan matriks densitas memiliki jejak sama dengan
satu. Jadi terlepas dari matriks densitas rho mana yang kita mulai, probabilitas hasil memang akan selalu membentuk
vektor probabilitas. Sekarang mari lihat beberapa contoh. Saya sudah menyebutkan bahwa
pengukuran projektif adalah kasus khusus dari pengukuran umum karena proyeksi selalu positif semi-definitif
tapi bagus untuk mulai dengan yang sederhana, jadi mari mulai dengan pengukuran basis standar dari sebuah qubit. Kita bisa merepresentasikan pengukuran basis standar
dari sebuah qubit dengan dua matriks P 0 dan P1 yang didefinisikan seperti yang ditunjukkan di layar. P 0 adalah ket 0 bra 0 dan P1 adalah ket 1
bra 1. Keduanya adalah matriks positif semi-definitif dan memang proyeksi, dan jelas berjumlah ke
identitas. Jadi bersama-sama mereka mendeskripsikan sebuah pengukuran. Jika kita menerapkan pengukuran ini pada qubit
dalam keadaan yang dideskripsikan oleh matriks densitas rho, maka probabilitas untuk hasil nol muncul adalah jejak dari P 0 dikali rho
dan probabilitas untuk hasil satu adalah jejak dari P1 dikali rho. Dan melalui sifat siklik dari jejak, kita mendapatkan
dua entri diagonal dari rho seperti yang kita harapkan. Berikut contoh lain di mana kali ini
matriks-matriksnya bukan proyeksi. Mereka memang positif semi-definitif dan kebetulan merupakan matriks densitas
tapi itu tidak penting. Yang penting adalah bahwa mereka berjumlah ke identitas sehingga bersama-sama mereka mendeskripsikan
sebuah pengukuran. Kita bisa lihat apa yang terjadi ketika pengukuran ini dilakukan pada qubit dalam keadaan plus misalnya, hanya untuk
melihat cara kerjanya untuk satu contoh keadaan, dan perhitungan probabilitasnya ditunjukkan di
layar. Perhatikan khususnya bahwa meskipun keadaan plus adalah keadaan murni dan kita bisa merepresentasikan keadaan itu dengan vektor keadaan Quantum ket plus, kita memang harus
memasukkan representasi matriks densitas dari keadaan itu yaitu ket plus bra plus ke dalam rumus untuk mendapatkan
probabilitas. Dan izinkan saya juga menyebutkan bahwa karena kita membicarakan tentang pengukuran destruktif, tidak ada
spesifikasi tentang keadaan Quantum dari qubit ini setelah pengukuran, jadi yang kita miliki hanyalah spesifikasi
probabilitas hasil. Berikut contoh terakhir untuk sekarang, dan ini cukup menarik. Sekali lagi ini adalah pengukuran dari
qubit tunggal, dan untuk mendeskripsikannya kita akan mulai dengan mendefinisikan empat vektor keadaan Quantum yang dikenal sebagai keadaan
tetrahedral. Dan alasan mereka disebut keadaan tetrahedral adalah karena mereka bersesuaian dengan empat sudut
dari tetrahedron biasa yang tertulis di dalam blok sphere. Dan untuk jelasnya ketika kita mengatakan ini adalah tetrahedron biasa,
yang kita maksud adalah padatan empat sisi di mana setiap mukanya adalah segitiga sama sisi. Jadi ada simetri sempurna di sini, setiap
rusuk memiliki panjang yang sama dan sudut yang sama terbentuk di antara dua rusuk yang berdekatan manapun.
Dan sekarang kita bisa mendefinisikan pengukuran menarik dengan empat kemungkinan hasil seperti yang ditunjukkan di layar. Atau dalam kata-kata, kita bisa mengambil
matriks-matriks kita sebagai representasi matriks densitas dari keadaan-keadaan ini dibagi dua. Sekarang ini memang positif
semi-definitif karena merupakan matriks densitas dibagi dua, dan kamu bisa melewati aritmatika untuk memeriksa
bahwa mereka memang berjumlah ke identitas. Tapi cara lain untuk melihatnya adalah dengan memikirkan simetrinya. Jika kita merata-ratakan keempat keadaan ini
bersama, kita mendapatkan keadaan sepenuhnya campur yang berada di tengah blok sphere. Tapi karena kita membagi
masing-masing dengan dua bukan empat, kita mendapatkan dua kali keadaan sepenuhnya campur yang merupakan identitas. Saya tidak akan mengatakan lebih banyak tentang
pengukuran ini untuk sekarang kecuali untuk mengamati bahwa ini bukan pengukuran projektif tapi ini adalah contoh yang bagus dan
kita akan melihatnya muncul lagi kemudian dalam pelajaran. Cara lain untuk mendeskripsikan pengukuran umum adalah sebagai channel seperti yang akan kita
diskusikan sekarang. Idenya di sini adalah bahwa keadaan probabilistik klasik bisa direpresentasikan oleh matriks densitas diagonal, dan
karena hasil pengukuran bersifat klasik, kita bisa memikirkan pengukuran sebagai channel di mana outputnya selalu berupa matriks densitas diagonal
WEBVTT
yang mendeskripsikan hasil pengukuran. Jadi mari lihat ini sedikit lebih detail. Jika kita berpikir secara
abstrak tentang pengukuran umum, kita bisa mendeskripsikan pengukuran tersebut sebagai channel fi. Sistem input untuk channel adalah
sistem X apapun yang sedang diukur, dan sistem output adalah sistem Y yang keadaan klasiknya bersesuaian dengan
hasil pengukuran yang kita ambil sebagai bilangan bulat dari 0 sampai N minus satu untuk bilangan bulat positif
M tertentu. Dan karena hasil pengukuran bersifat klasik, kita mensyaratkan bahwa untuk setiap matriks densitas input rho untuk sistem
X, output fi dari rho harus berupa matriks densitas diagonal. Misalnya jika kita memikirkan pengukuran basis standar
dari sebuah qubit dan kita memikirkan pengukuran tersebut sebagai yang dideskripsikan oleh sebuah channel, kita bisa mengungkapkannya seperti yang ada di sini di layar.
Jika matriks densitas input adalah rho, maka kita akan mendapatkan hasil nol dengan probabilitas sama dengan bra 0 rho ket nol
dan kita akan mendapatkan hasil satu dengan probabilitas bra satu rho ket satu. Jadi jika kita mengungkapkan hasil
pengukuran klasik ini sebagai matriks densitas, kita akan mendapatkan ekspresi ini untuk channel yang bersesuaian. Dan ternyata
tidak lain adalah channel completely dephasing. Dan itu konsisten dengan ide bahwa channel completely dephasing
merepresentasikan bentuk ekstrim dari decoherence yang bisa berarti hal yang berbeda, tapi ketika saya menggunakan istilah itu saya
berbicara tentang kecenderungan keadaan Quantum untuk menjadi klasik karena lingkungan di sekitar sistem apapun yang kita
bicarakan sedang mengamati dalam arti tertentu, atau dengan kata lain, sedang mengukur.
Jadi hasil pengukuran bisa dideskripsikan sebagai channel seperti yang baru saja saya deskripsikan, tapi ini bukan hanya sebuah kemungkinan, ini adalah
karakterisasi dari pengukuran umum, dan yang saya maksud dengan itu adalah sebagai berikut. Tentu saja ada channel
yang tidak merepresentasikan pengukuran karena outputnya mungkin tidak selalu berupa matriks densitas diagonal. Tapi jika memang
kasusnya bahwa output dari sebuah channel selalu berupa matriks densitas diagonal terlepas dari keadaan input rho yang kita pilih, maka tentu saja mungkin untuk
mengungkapkan channel tersebut dalam bentuk yang ditunjukkan di layar untuk beberapa pilihan pengukuran, yaitu koleksi dari matriks positif semi-definitif yang berjumlah ke identitas.
Dan itu bagus untuk berbagai alasan termasuk fakta bahwa ini pada dasarnya memberi tahu kita bahwa definisi kita tentang pengukuran sebagai koleksi matriks tidak kehilangan
apapun. Cara lain untuk mengatakan ini adalah bahwa cara memikirkan pengukuran sebagai channel ini bersifat operasional
atau mungkin aksiomatis dalam arti bahwa ini menangkap apa yang seharusnya menjadi pengukuran, yaitu proses fisik yang
mengubah informasi Quantum menjadi informasi klasik. Dan ternyata ini sepenuhnya ekuivalen dengan deskripsi pertama kita
tentang pengukuran yang bersifat murni aljabar. Saya tidak akan membuktikan ekuivalensinya dalam video ini tapi
ini tidak sulit dan jika kamu tertarik kamu bisa menemukan buktinya dalam materi tertulis untuk pelajaran yang ditautkan dalam deskripsi video.
Kita telah mendiskusikan apa yang terjadi ketika pengukuran umum dilakukan pada sistem dalam keadaan tertentu,
setidaknya untuk kasus pengukuran destruktif. Selanjutnya kita akan membicarakan tentang pengukuran parsial, artinya hanya
satu bagian dari sistem majemuk yang diukur. Untuk tepat, anggap kita memiliki sepasang sistem XZ yang
bersama-sama berada dalam keadaan yang dideskripsikan oleh matriks densitas rho, dan pengukuran yang dideskripsikan oleh koleksi matriks positif semi-definitif yang berjumlah ke
identitas dilakukan pada sistem X saja. Secara alami ini menghasilkan
hasil pengukuran, dan karena kita membicarakan tentang pengukuran destruktif, kita bisa membayangkan bahwa proses pengukuran menghancurkan sistem
X. Tapi kita masih punya sistem Z yang perlu dikhawatirkan dan kita perlu memahami bagaimana pengukuran X mempengaruhi
keadaan Z. Pertama mari bicarakan tentang probabilitas
hasil. Karena kita membicarakan tentang pengukuran sistem X saja, probabilitas untuk hasil yang berbeda
muncul hanya bisa bergantung pada keadaan X secara terisolasi, yaitu hanya bisa bergantung pada
keadaan tereduksi dari X. Khususnya, probabilitas untuk hasil tertentu A muncul diberikan oleh
rumus yang sama dari sebelumnya yaitu jejak dari PA dikali keadaan tereduksi dari X yang kita notasikan dengan rho
subX. Keadaan rho subX diperoleh dari rho dengan men-trace-out Z, jadi kita bisa melakukan
substitusi itu, dan meskipun mungkin tidak langsung jelas, pertanyaan yang kita dapatkan secara alternatif bisa dituliskan seperti yang
ditunjukkan di layar. Itu adalah jejak dari PA di-tensor dengan matriks identitas pada sistem Z dikali
rho. Sekarang itu adalah persamaan yang pasti layak untuk diverifikasi. Ini intuitif, kita tidak melakukan
apa-apa pada Z sehingga masuk akal bahwa identitas pada Z muncul seperti ini, tapi itu juga bisa diverifikasi
secara aljabar dan saya akan biarkan itu untukmu, beserta saran untuk pertama mempertimbangkan kasus di mana rho adalah perkalian tensor dari dua matriks lalu
gunakan linearitas untuk menyimpulkan bahwa itu harus bekerja untuk semua rho. Dan saya juga akan mengatakan bahwa itu tidak bergantung pada fakta bahwa PA
positif semi-definitif atau bahwa rho adalah matriks densitas. Ini adalah persamaan yang akan bekerja untuk pilihan matriks apapun
sebagai pengganti PA dan rho selama mereka memiliki dimensi yang benar agar ekspresi tersebut masuk
akal. Dan sekarang mari lihat bagaimana keadaan Z dipengaruhi oleh pengukuran. Dan pendekatan alami
menurut saya adalah memikirkan pengukuran sebagai channel. Berikut adalah channel yang kita asosiasikan dengan pengukuran kita, dan kita
memikirkan ini sebagai channel dari sistem X ke sistem Y baru yang keadaan klasiknya bersesuaian dengan hasil pengukuran. Jadi dalam rumus ini
Sigma merepresentasikan keadaan dari sistem X saja. Jika kita menerapkan channel ini ke
sistem X sementara pasangan XZ berada dalam keadaan rho, maka kita akan mendapatkan matriks densitas yang ada di sini.
Sekali lagi, luangkan waktu sebanyak yang kamu butuhkan untuk memverifikasi ini, dan sekali lagi saran saya adalah pertama mempertimbangkan kasus di mana rho adalah perkalian tensor
dari dua matriks lalu gunakan linearitas. Sekarang kita melihat tipe keadaan ini
di mana sistem pertama adalah klasik dan sistem kedua adalah Quantum sebagai contoh dalam pelajaran
matriks densitas. Setiap A muncul dengan probabilitas tertentu dan itulah jejak dari faktor tensor kedua sehingga kamu bisa memikirkan
faktor tensor kedua ini sebagai matriks densitas yang dikalikan dengan probabilitas. Jadi untuk mendapatkan keadaan
Z yang dikondisikan pada mendapatkan hasil pengukuran tertentu A, kita cukup membagi probabilitasnya, atau dengan kata lain kita
menormalisasi faktor tensor kedua dengan membaginya dengan jejaknya sendiri. Jadi singkatnya jika kita melakukan
pengukuran pada X sementara pasangan XZ berada dalam keadaan rho, inilah yang terjadi. Pertama setiap hasil A muncul
dengan probabilitas sama dengan jejak dari PA di-tensor dengan identitas dikali rho. Dan kedua, dikondisikan pada mendapatkan
WEBVTT
hasil pengukuran tertentu A, keadaan Z diberikan oleh ekspresi yang ditunjukkan di layar yang merupakan yang kita dapatkan
dengan menormalisasi matriks yang baru saja kita lihat tadi. Dan itu sama dengan membagi matriks tersebut dengan probabilitas
untuk A muncul. Saya perlu menyebutkan bahwa ini hanya masuk akal jika probabilitasnya non-nol karena kalau tidak kita
membagi dengan nol, tapi tidak apa-apa karena kita tidak perlu memikirkan hal-hal yang tidak terjadi. Dalam bagian
pelajaran ini kita akan mendiskusikan teorema sederhana tapi mendasar tentang pengukuran yang dikenal sebagai teorema
Naimark. Singkatnya, apa yang dikatakannya adalah bahwa pengukuran apapun bisa diimplementasikan seperti yang disarankan gambar di layar.
Dalam kata-kata, pengukuran umum tertentu pada sistem X bisa diimplementasikan dengan cara berikut.
Pertama kita memperkenalkan sistem workspace Y yang sudah diinisialisasi yang keadaan klasiknya adalah kemungkinan hasil pengukuran yang kita asumsikan bernomor
0 sampai N minus satu. Kemudian operasi unitary U dilakukan pada pasangan
YX, lalu pengukuran basis standar dilakukan pada Y. Jadi semuanya pada dasarnya sudah
ditentukan di sini kecuali pilihan U, dan yang dikatakan teorema adalah bahwa memang mungkin untuk memilih operasi unitary
U ini sehingga probabilitas untuk hasil yang berbeda selalu sesuai dengan pengukuran umum yang
diberikan. Sekarang mari lihat bagaimana teorema Naimark dibuktikan, dan ini tidak sulit. Kita hanya perlu membuat pilihan yang baik untuk
operasi unitary U dan memverifikasi bahwa itu berhasil. Tapi pertama kita memerlukan fakta dasar
dari teori matriks yaitu bahwa untuk matriks positif semi-definitif P manapun, selalu ada matriks positif semi-definitif yang unik
Q sedemikian sehingga Q kuadrat sama dengan P. Secara umum ada banyak matriks yang dikuadratkan memberikan kita P tapi
selalu hanya ada satu yang positif semi-definitif. Notasi yang kita gunakan untuk menunjukkan matriks ini adalah akar kuadrat dari
P dan begitulah juga cara kita menyebutnya dalam kata-kata. Jika kamu ingin menghitung akar kuadrat dari P untuk matriks positif semi-definitif P tertentu
omong-omong, kamu bisa melakukannya dengan pertama menghitung dekomposisi spektral dari P lalu
mengganti setiap nilai eigen dengan akar kuadratnya dan membiarkan vektor eigen tetap. Nilai eigennya semua non-
negatif jadi ini masuk akal, dan cukup mudah untuk melihat bahwa matriks yang kita dapatkan memang positif semi-definitif
dan dikuadratkan menjadi P. Fakta bahwa itu unik adalah masalah yang berbeda, tidak sulit untuk
membuktikannya menggunakan beberapa fakta dasar tentang matriks tapi ini agak melenceng dari pelajaran dan kita hanya akan menerima bagian
itu. Dan sekarang setelah kita memiliki konsep itu, cukup mudah untuk menentukan
operasi unitary U yang berhasil. Matriks unitary manapun yang cocok dengan pola yang ditunjukkan di layar akan
bekerja. N kolom pertama, dengan asumsi X memiliki N keadaan klasik seperti sebelumnya, diperoleh dengan menumpuk akar kuadrat dari
matriks yang mendeskripsikan pengukuran di atas satu sama lain, dan kolom-kolom yang tersisa bisa apapun yang kita
inginkan, tidak ada bedanya selama seluruh matriksnya unitary.
Dan omong-omong jika kamu memperhatikan kemiripan dengan hubungan antara representasi Kraus dan Stinespring dari channel, itu bukan kebetulan. Dan
sebenarnya yang kita miliki di sini adalah pada dasarnya kasus khusus dari itu di mana matriks Kraus kita semua kebetulan positif
semi-definitif. Jadi ada dua hal yang perlu kita periksa. Yang pertama adalah bahwa pilihan U ini memang berhasil dan yang
kedua adalah bahwa mungkin untuk memilih kolom-kolom yang tidak ditentukan dengan cara yang membuat U unitary. Jadi mari mulai dengan yang pertama.
Berikut keadaan yang kita mulai. Sistem bawah Y diinisialisasi ke keadaan nol sementara sistem atas
dimulai dalam keadaan rho, lalu kita melakukan U yang berarti kita mengkonjugasi dengan
U. Kita bisa menuliskan semuanya dalam hal matriks blok seperti yang ditunjukkan di layar. Kita punya U di sebelah kiri, U dagger di
sebelah kanan, dan ket nol bra nol di-tensor dengan rho di tengah yang mengambil bentuk yang kita miliki di sini di mana kita memiliki rho di
pojok kiri atas dan nol di mana-mana. Dan jika kamu memikirkan perkalian ini sebentar, terlihat jelas bahwa
entri yang tidak ditentukan dari U tidak berpengaruh sama sekali karena mereka selalu dikalikan dengan entri nol dari matriks
di tengah. Dan jika kita melewati perkalian, yang kita dapatkan adalah
matriks yang ditunjukkan di sini yang dideskripsikan sebagai matriks blok, atau secara alternatif kita bisa mengungkapkannya menggunakan notasi bra-ket
seperti ini. Itu sebenarnya bentuk yang lebih nyaman untuk kita sehingga mari fokus pada
ekspresi ini. Dan demi kenyamanan, mari beri nama matriks ini yang merupakan matriks densitas dengan nama
Sigma. Langkah terakhir adalah pengukuran basis standar pada Y sehingga mari hitung keadaan tereduksi dalam Y dan
itu mudah mengingat ekspresi yang kita miliki. Kita cukup men-trace-out X yang bersesuaian dengan faktor tensor kedua.
Jadi probabilitas untuk hasil tertentu A muncul adalah entri diagonal yang bersesuaian dengan A. Kita bisa menulis
itu seperti ini dan itu sama dengan jejak dari akar kuadrat PA dikali rho dikali akar kuadrat
PA. Dan melalui sifat siklik dari jejak kita mendapatkan jejak dari PA dikali rho
yang merupakan yang kita harapkan. Jadi probabilitas untuk hasil yang berbeda muncul adalah benar, mereka selalu sesuai
dengan pengukuran asli yang kita mulai. Hal kedua yang perlu kita periksa
adalah bahwa mungkin untuk mengisi kolom-kolom yang tidak ditentukan dari U dengan cara yang membuatnya
unitary. Ini mengikuti dari fakta bahwa N kolom pertama yang merupakan yang dibentuk oleh akar kuadrat dari matriks yang mendeskripsikan
pengukuran adalah ortonormal, dan itu bisa diperiksa cukup langsung. Detail yang relevan ada di sini
di layar jadi pause video dan luangkan beberapa momen untuk memikirkan itu jika kamu mau. Tapi seperti yang saya sarankan sebelumnya,
ini sebenarnya adalah kasus khusus dari sesuatu yang kita temui di pelajaran sebelumnya dan itulah
buktinya. Sejauh ini dalam pelajaran ini kita telah fokus pada pengukuran destruktif yang berarti tidak ada spesifikasi
tentang keadaan Quantum dari sistem yang diukur setelah pengukuran. Untuk pengukuran non-destruktif di sisi lain, ada
bukan hanya hasil pengukuran klasik tapi juga keadaan Quantum dari sistem yang diukur setelah pengukuran, dan seperti
yang akan kita lihat, ada hubungan alami dengan teorema Naimark. Sebenarnya ada cara berbeda untuk memformulasikan pengukuran non-destruktif
dalam istilah matematika, tapi kita akan mulai dengan satu formulasi yang pada dasarnya datang langsung dari teorema Naimark.
Pertimbangkan pengukuran umum yaitu yang destruktif yang dideskripsikan oleh koleksi matriks positif semi-definitif
P 0 sampai PN minus satu yang berjumlah ke identitas. Kita kemudian bisa mengubah
WEBVTT
pengukuran ini menjadi pengukuran non-destruktif cukup dengan mempertimbangkan implementasi dari pengukuran ini yang kita diskusikan dalam konteks teorema Naimark.
Kita memperkenalkan sistem Y baru, berinteraksi dengannya melalui operasi unitary U, dan kemudian melakukan pengukuran basis standar
pada Y. Jadi sistem X masih ada dan kita bisa mempertimbangkan
keadaannya. Dan berdasarkan analisis yang sudah kita lalui, kita bisa menentukan bahwa keadaan X setelah pengukuran yang dikondisikan pada
mendapatkan hasil pengukuran tertentu A diberikan oleh matriks densitas yang terlihat seperti
ini. Dalam kata-kata, kita mengkonjugasi dengan akar kuadrat dari matriks pengukuran yang bersesuaian dan kemudian
menormalisasi. Cara lain untuk memformulasikan pengukuran non-destruktif yang lebih umum adalah dalam hal matriks Kraus
dari channel, dan ini adalah definisi pengukuran yang akan kamu temukan dalam buku teks terkenal dari Nielsen dan
Chuang misalnya. Anggap bahwa M0 sampai MM minus 1 adalah matriks persegi yang memenuhi
persamaan yang ditunjukkan di layar, yang artinya kita bisa memikirkan matriks-matriks ini sebagai matriks Kraus yang mendeskripsikan
channel. Sebenarnya matriks-matriks ini memang mendeskripsikan sebuah channel tapi mereka juga mendeskripsikan pengukuran non-destruktif.
Dan cara kerjanya ketika sistem dalam keadaan rho tertentu diukur adalah pertama probabilitas hasil
diberikan oleh persamaan yang ditunjukkan di layar. Setiap hasil muncul dengan probabilitas sama dengan jejak dari MA dikali
rho dikali MA dagger. Dan dikondisikan pada hasil A yang muncul, keadaan dari sistem yang diukur
terlihat seperti ini. Pengukuran non-destruktif seperti ini bisa diimplementasikan dengan
cara yang serupa dengan yang kita miliki untuk teorema Naimark dan saya biarkan itu untukmu pikirkan jika kamu
mau. Memang mungkin untuk menggeneralisasi konsep pengukuran non-destruktif bahkan lebih jauh dari ini. Misalnya,
ada konsep yang disebut instrumen Quantum yang kadang-kadang cukup berguna, tapi saya tidak akan membahasnya dalam
video ini. Di bagian terakhir pelajaran ini, saya akan membahas secara singkat dua tugas yang terkait dengan pengukuran: diskriminasi Quantum State dan tomografi
Quantum State. Ada banyak hal yang bisa dikatakan tentang kedua konsep ini dan kita benar-benar hanya akan menyentuh
permukaannya. Jadi mari mulai dengan mengklarifikasi apa yang dimaksud dengan istilah-istilah ini dan bagaimana mereka berbeda.
Pertama adalah diskriminasi Quantum State. Idenya di sini adalah bahwa kita memiliki koleksi keadaan Quantum yang diketahui
dari suatu sistem beserta probabilitas yang terkait dengan keadaan-keadaan ini. Jadi untuk tepatnya, anggap
bahwa rho 0 sampai rho M minus 1 adalah matriks densitas yang merepresentasikan kemungkinan keadaan Quantum dari sistem X, dan P 0
sampai PN minus satu adalah probabilitas yang terkait dengan keadaan-keadaan ini. Jadi jika kita mengumpulkan probabilitas ke dalam satu
vektor, kita mendapatkan vektor probabilitas. Cara singkat untuk mengatakan ini omong-omong adalah bahwa kita memiliki ensemble keadaan Quantum.
Dan sekarang cara abstrak yang bisa kita pikirkan tentang diskriminasi Quantum State sebagai tugas atau sebagai masalah
adalah bahwa pertama sebuah angka antara nol dan N minus satu dipilih secara acak sesuai dengan probabilitas. Sistem X kemudian
dipersiapkan dalam keadaan yang bersesuaian dengan angka yang dipilih secara acak, dan tujuannya adalah untuk menentukan melalui
pengukuran X angka mana yang dipilih. Jadi kita punya sejumlah terbatas
alternatif beserta prior, dan tujuannya adalah untuk menentukan alternatif mana yang sebenarnya terjadi. Untuk beberapa pilihan keadaan dan
probabilitas, ini mungkin mudah, dan untuk yang lain mungkin tidak mungkin untuk melakukan ini tanpa kemungkinan membuat kesalahan.
Dan ada berbagai pertanyaan spesifik yang bisa kita tanyakan seperti apa probabilitas minimum untuk membuat kesalahan
dan seperti apa pengukuran yang mencapai probabilitas kesalahan minimum ini. Tomografi Quantum State di sisi lain
adalah berbeda. Di sini kita memiliki keadaan Quantum yang tidak diketahui dari sebuah sistem, jadi biasanya
tidak ada prior atau informasi tentang kemungkinan alternatif. Kali ini bagaimanapun, bukan satu salinan keadaan yang tersedia
melainkan banyak salinan independen yang tersedia, artinya untuk beberapa angka N yang mungkin besar, kita memiliki N sistem identik X1 sampai XN yang masing-masing
dipersiapkan secara independen dalam keadaan
rho. Dan kali ini tujuannya adalah untuk menemukan aproksimasi dari keadaan Quantum yang tidak diketahui ini sebagai matriks densitas dengan mengukur
sistem-sistemnya. Jadi singkatnya, dalam diskriminasi Quantum State kita memiliki satu salinan
keadaan dan kita mencoba mendiskriminasikan di antara sejumlah terbatas alternatif yang diketahui, dan dalam tomografi Quantum State kita memiliki banyak salinan independen
dari keadaan Quantum yang tidak diketahui dan tujuannya adalah menemukan deskripsi dari keadaan itu atau setidaknya aproksimasi yang layak
darinya. Diskriminasi Quantum State itu menarik karena mengabstraksikan tipe situasi yang biasanya muncul dalam
komputasi dan kriptografi misalnya, di mana satu alternatif dari sekumpulan kemungkinan terbatas telah terjadi dan kita atau orang lain sedang mencoba
mencari tahu mana itu dengan mengukur sistem Quantum. Kasus non-trivial yang paling sederhana adalah
ketika hanya ada dua alternatif yang berarti M sama dengan dua, sehingga tugasnya adalah mendiskriminasikan antara sepasang
keadaan. Kasus ini ternyata adalah masalah yang pada dasarnya sepenuhnya terselesaikan dengan asumsi tujuannya adalah untuk meminimalkan
kemungkinan diskriminasi yang salah. Ada pilihan optimal untuk pengukuran dan sering disebut
pengukuran Helstrom. Ini sebenarnya adalah pengukuran projektif dan bisa dideskripsikan sebagai
berikut. Pertama kita mempertimbangkan perbedaan tertimbang antara dua alternatif yaitu P 0 dikali rho 0 minus P1 dikali rho satu.
Jadi kita mengalikan probabilitas menggambar masing-masing dari dua keadaan ini ke keadaan itu sendiri, dan kita mengambil
perbedaannya. Itu adalah matriks Hermitian karena sama dengan transpose conjugate-nya sendiri, sehingga memiliki dekomposisi spektral
dan kita tahu khususnya bahwa nilai eigennya semua bilangan real. Jadi anggap kita memiliki
dekomposisi spektral yang ditulis dalam bentuk yang ditunjukkan di layar. Yang kita lakukan selanjutnya adalah mengumpulkan
nilai eigen ke dalam dua himpunan di mana semua nilai eigen positif ada dalam satu himpunan dan semua nilai eigen negatif ada dalam
himpunan lain. Untuk tepatnya, ambil S0 sebagai himpunan dari semua indeks K yang nilai eigennya Lambda K yang bersesuaian adalah
non-negatif, dan biarkan S1 menjadi indeks yang tersisa yang merupakan yang bersesuaian dengan nilai eigen
negatif. Sebenarnya tidak ada bedanya himpunan mana yang berisi indeks yang bersesuaian dengan nilai eigen nol manapun di sini, kita membuat
pilihan sembarang untuk memasukkan minus nol tapi tidak akan ada bedanya jika sebagian atau semua dari mereka dimasukkan ke S1 sebagai gantinya. Yang benar-benar penting adalah
bahwa kita memisahkan nilai eigen positif dan negatif. Dan akhirnya kita mendefinisikan dua proyeksi Pi
0 dan Pi 1 seperti yang ditunjukkan di layar. Dalam kata-kata, Pi 0 adalah proyeksi ke
WEBVTT
subruang yang dibentang oleh vektor eigen yang bersesuaian dengan nilai eigen non-negatif, dan Pi 1 adalah proyeksi ke ruang
yang dibentang oleh vektor eigen yang bersesuaian dengan nilai eigen negatif. Ini memang proyeksi dan
jika kita menjumlahkannya, kita mendapatkan matriks identitas karena vektor eigen S 0 sampai S N minus satu membentuk
basis ortonormal. Jika pengukuran ini dilakukan dalam situasi yang ada yaitu bahwa
keadaan yang diukur adalah rho 0 dengan probabilitas P 0 dan rho satu dengan probabilitas P1, maka ternyata
probabilitas identifikasi yang benar memiliki formula yang cukup sederhana dalam hal nilai eigen Lambda 0 sampai Lambda N minus
satu. Saya tidak akan membahas detail perhitungan dalam video ini. Kamu bisa berkonsultasi dengan konten tertulis yang tertaut di deskripsi video jika kamu
tertarik, atau coba kamu meyakinkan dirimu bahwa formula ini memang benar. Kita juga bisa mengungkapkan
probabilitas ini menggunakan norma matriks yang umumnya disebut trace norm. Ini notasi yang mirip dengan norma Euclidean untuk vektor
kecuali bahwa kita punya subskrip satu untuk menunjukkan bahwa itu adalah trace norm. Trace norm sangat penting dan sangat
umum ditemui dalam Quantum Computing tapi saya tidak akan mengatakan terlalu banyak lagi tentangnya dalam pelajaran ini. Satu cara untuk
mendefinisikannya untuk matriks Hermitian adalah bahwa itu adalah jumlah dari nilai mutlak dari nilai eigen, sehingga kamu bisa memikirkan
persamaan kedua ini sebagai mengikuti langsung dari definisi tersebut. Trace norm juga bisa
didefinisikan dengan cara lain yang lebih umum dan kita akan menemukan trace norm lagi di pelajaran berikutnya. Ini sebenarnya
adalah yang terbaik yang bisa kamu lakukan. Pengukuran ini optimal dengan asumsi tujuanmu adalah memaksimalkan kemungkinan tebakan
yang benar. Fakta itu kadang-kadang disebut teorema Helstrom-Holevo dan kadang-kadang juga disebut saja teorema
Helstrom. Jadi kamu tidak bisa mengalahkan pengukuran ini dalam hal probabilitas kebenaran, dan itu bagus karena
ada resep sederhana untuk pengukuran itu sendiri dan formula tepat untuk probabilitas kebenaran dalam hal trace
norm. Trace norm sering digunakan sebagai cara mengukur perbedaan yang dapat diamati antara matriks densitas untuk
alasan ini khususnya. Dan ketika orang menyebut jarak trace antara keadaan, mereka biasanya mengacu pada
setengah kali trace norm dari perbedaan antara dua matriks densitas, yang di sini bersesuaian dengan kasus di mana P 0 dan P1 keduanya 1/2 yang
merupakan kasus alami untuk dipertimbangkan. Diskriminasi Quantum State untuk dua keadaan diselesaikan secara optimal oleh
pengukuran Helstrom yang mana kita memiliki resep sederhana dan formula sederhana untuk probabilitas
kebenaran. Jadi apa yang terjadi ketika kita ingin mendiskriminasikan di antara tiga atau lebih keadaan? Dalam kasus ini kita tidak memiliki
formula secara umum untuk pilihan optimal dari sebuah pengukuran atau ekspresi sederhana untuk probabilitas maksimum
kebenaran. Namun memungkinkan untuk menemukan aproksimasi yang baik dari pengukuran optimal dengan bantuan komputer.
Dan khususnya itu bisa dilakukan menggunakan teknik optimasi yang benar-benar menakjubkan dan kuat yang dikenal sebagai pemrograman semi-definitif, tapi bukan
sesuatu yang bisa kamu implementasikan secara layak menggunakan pensil dan kertas misalnya. Di sisi lain jika seseorang
memberimu deskripsi pengukuran dan mereka mengklaim bahwa pengukuran ini optimal untuk tugas diskriminasi Quantum State, maka
sebenarnya sangat mudah untuk memverifikasi atau memalsukan klaim tersebut, dan itu bisa dilakukan menggunakan yang disebut kondisi
Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax. Saya tidak akan menjelaskan apa itu dalam video ini tapi mereka adalah kondisi sederhana dan cukup keren
bahwa ini mungkin. Berikut contoh yang menghubungkan kembali ke keadaan tetrahedral
yang kita lihat sebelumnya dalam pelajaran. Misalkan kita diberi salah satu dari empat keadaan ini yang dipilih secara acak dengan
probabilitas satu per empat untuk masing-masing, dan tujuan kita adalah menentukan keadaan mana yang kita beri. Mungkin tidak mengherankan tapi
pilihan terbaik yang bisa kamu buat untuk pengukuran guna melakukan ini adalah pengukuran tetrahedral. Kamu tidak selalu bisa
melakukan sesuatu seperti ini untuk koleksi keadaan murni yang sembarang, tapi karena simetri yang terlibat di sini, ini memang
berhasil dan kita benar-benar mendapatkan pengukuran yang valid. Dan melalui kondisi Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax yang saya sebutkan
beberapa saat lalu, ternyata cukup mudah untuk membuktikan bahwa ini memang pilihan optimal dari
pengukuran. Secara khusus, yang terjadi di sini adalah bahwa pengukuran selalu benar dengan probabilitas 1/2 yang tidak
buruk karena ada empat alternatif sehingga probabilitas tebakan yang benar dua kali lebih baik dari tebakan acak, dan itu
kebetulan adalah yang terbaik yang bisa kamu lakukan untuk keadaan-keadaan ini. Sekarang saya akan sedikit lagi tentang tomografi Quantum State
di mana kita memiliki banyak salinan independen dari keadaan Quantum yang tidak diketahui dan tujuannya adalah menemukan aproksimasi dari matriks densitas yang mendeskripsikan
keadaan itu. Sebenarnya ada beberapa varian berbeda dari masalah ini yang bergantung pada asumsimu dan khususnya
pada tipe pengukuran apa yang kamu izinkan. Misalnya, kita bisa menuntut bahwa setiap sistem diukur secara individual dan
hasilnya digabungkan entah bagaimana untuk sampai pada deskripsi matriks densitas, atau kita bisa mengizinkan semua
sistem diukur bersama sebagai satu sistem majemuk yang jauh lebih baik secara teori tapi juga jauh lebih
menuntut dari sudut pandang teknologi. Selain pilihan yang dibuat untuk pengukuran, ada
juga pertimbangan penting yaitu bagaimana merekonstruksi deskripsi matriks densitas dari data apapun yang kamu
dapatkan dari pengukuran. Saya tidak akan masuk ke detail tentang ini. Poin saya hanya untuk menyarankan
bahwa tomografi Quantum State sebenarnya lebih merupakan konsep payung yang memiliki banyak varian berbeda sebagai lawan dari menjadi
prosedur tunggal. Ada banyak penelitian tentang masalah ini termasuk beberapa
hasil terobosan yang cukup baru yang menghubungkan jumlah salinan N dengan akurasi aproksimasi yang bisa diperoleh, dan ini terus menjadi
area penelitian yang menarik dan aktif. Untuk mengakhiri pelajaran ini, mari lihat tomografi Quantum State
untuk qubit dan bagaimana kita bisa melakukannya. Jadi anggap rho adalah matriks densitas yang merepresentasikan keadaan dari
qubit tunggal, dan X1 sampai XN adalah qubit yang semuanya telah dipersiapkan secara independen dalam keadaan rho, dan untuk
keperluan diskusi ini anggap N adalah besar. Yang bisa kita lakukan adalah membagi
sistem-sistem menjadi tiga tumpukan yang kira-kira sama besar, dan untuk tumpukan pertama kita akan melakukan pengukuran terhadap basis plus
minus. Untuk setiap hasil yang bersesuaian dengan plus, kita akan mencatat plus satu dan untuk setiap
hasil yang bersesuaian dengan minus, kita akan mencatat minus satu. Cara yang lebih singkat untuk mendeskripsikan pengukuran ini
adalah bahwa itu adalah pengukuran Pauli X karena keadaan plus dan minus adalah vektor eigen dari matriks Pauli X dan
nilai eigen yang bersesuaian adalah plus satu dan minus satu. Dan sebenarnya itu juga cara yang jauh lebih umum untuk mendeskripsikannya, dan
WEBVTT
memang nilai yang diharapkan untuk skor sama dengan jejak dari Sigma X dikali rho. Sekarang kita tidak harus belajar apa
nilai yang diharapkan ini tapi jika kita merata-ratakan skor yang kita peroleh selama banyak percobaan, kita kemungkinan besar akan mendapatkan
aproksimasi yang layak untuk nilai yang diharapkan ini berdasarkan hukum bilangan besar. Dan ada beberapa batas statistik terkenal yang bisa kita gunakan untuk
ini jika kita ingin lebih kuantitatif tentang pernyataan tersebut. Kita melakukan sesuatu yang serupa dengan Sigma Y pada sepertiga kedua dari
sistem. Satu-satunya hal yang berubah di sini adalah bahwa kita menggunakan keadaan plus I dan minus I yang merupakan vektor eigen dari Sigma
Y, dan demikian pula untuk Sigma Z yang mana vektor basis standar adalah vektor
eigen. Dan kemudian akhirnya kita bisa menggunakan formula yang ditunjukkan di layar yang memberi tahu kita apa koefisiennya harus
jika rho ditulis sebagai kombinasi linear dari matriks Pauli, dan dengan mensubstitusikan aproksimasi kita untuk koefisien-koefisien ini
dan mungkin sedikit menyesuaikannya untuk memastikan bahwa kita mendapatkan matriks positif semi-definitif, kita mendapatkan aproksimasi untuk
rho. Tentu saja ada detail yang belum saya bahas seperti akurasi aproksimasi dan tingkat
kepercayaan yang bisa kita harapkan dalam itu, tapi semoga itu memberimu ide dasar tentang satu cara tomografi bisa dilakukan pada
qubit. Juga mungkin untuk melakukan tomografi qubit menggunakan pengukuran tetrahedral, dan ternyata ini
cukup sederhana dan elegan setidaknya dalam istilah matematika. Yang bisa kita lakukan adalah melakukan hanya
pengukuran ini saja pada semua salinan independen dari keadaan Quantum kita yang tidak diketahui, dan dengan menggunakan
formula luar biasa yang ditunjukkan di sini, kita bisa menghasilkan aproksimasi dari keadaan kita dengan memperkirakan jejak dari PK dikali
rho untuk setiap K berdasarkan fraksi waktu hasil pengukuran yang bersesuaian muncul. Sekali lagi ini hanya berhasil karena
simetri sempurna yang kita miliki di antara keempat keadaan ini, dan sebenarnya ada beberapa masalah menarik yang belum terselesaikan yang berkaitan dengan generalisasi
dari pendekatan ini ke sistem yang lebih besar. Dan itu adalah tempat yang baik untuk mengakhiri pelajaran. Terima kasih sudah menonton dan saya
harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk pelajaran berikutnya yang tentang purifikasi dan Fidelity. Sampai jumpa.